I started practicing Aikido in April 1978.
I was 22 years old.
I liked Budo
so I wanted to practice it, something like either Kendo or Judo.
As it happened, one of my friends who was doing Aikido invited me to have a look at a class.
That is the only reason really.
I started Aikido Kyoto about 10 years ago, it will be 11 years this year.
The Nishijin Dojo was established 6 years ago.
I haven't really faced any particular difficulties, really.
However, before even starting to talk about Aikido, I did face obstacles because I am Japanese, and I am a woman.
But rather than difficulties, I would say that these were more like social prejudices.
So within Aikido itself, I did not experience any particular difficulties.
I would say that Aikido as an art is very impartial and equalitarian.
I actually reckon that there are more advantages than difficulties.
In my teaching, the techniques are basically the same.
That being said there are some differences,
some people are tall, some are short,
some are big, some are small,
there are children, adults, etc.
This is why I think that a technique should work and make sense for everybody.
But of course, there are some elements of a technique that must be changed while others that have to remain the same.
If the partner changes something, we have to change accordingly.
That is why I think that form is not something that should be used to fit something into a specific shape, but that there should be some level of flexibility.
This is a very difficult question.
Basically, I practiced at Hombu Dojo with many Sensei.
I received from many of the Sensei there, including of course Ueshiba Kisshomau Doshu.
In France, I learnt from Christian Tissier Sensei who had also studied at Hombu.
I learnt from all those people.
I processed all of that and I decided to teach the product of that reflection to other people.
My main influence is Yamaguchi Sensei.
After that, it is Tissier Sensei,
and then Shibata Sensei.
It is up to you to practice basics daily at your own dojo.
According to the kind of keiko you do, your perception will improve and that will again change the way you train.
There are people who only perceive the form because they have not been really educated.
Consequently, they only know to mimic the form of their teachers.
Of course sometimes, learning to some extent involves copying,
but not seeing only what can be seen, training is to learn to see what is not visible, and the role of the instruction is to guide in this process.
You have to train yourself to perceive what can't be seen.
Aikido is a budo that helps to cultivate this sort of insight.
I really think so.
The reason is that for all sports professionals, beyond the competition,
it is the dedicated, every day personal training that occupies most of the time,
so I think that daily training is the most important.
I mainly do some stretching and sometimes suburi, that is all.
I have to keep a daily routine, take care of my health, eat good food, take care of my body, and avoid wasting energy.
At Aikido Kyoto, we practice weapons 2h every week.
There are 2 classes.
Weapons training is very helpful in order to deepen one's study of Aikido.
Personally however, I don't see myself as a kenjutsu-ka,
I am have not reached a level where I am aiming at mastering the weapons.
However, I am doing this study because it helps my Aikido with elements such as distance and timing.
At that time when I started, Masuda Sensei was sometimes teaching tanto-dori
and I also used to take special weapons classes twice per week with Shibata Sensei, learning Aiki-ken and Aiki-jo.
When I got to America, I also did weapons at the Birankai with Chiba Sensei.
Before they reach sandan or yondan, students should develop a good eye to perceive the essence of Aikido.
It is our responsibility to helps them achieve this.
We have a kenshusei program at Aikido Kyoto.
This program is for those who want to become Aikido teachers,
either professionally or semi-professionally,
for anyone who wants to teach at some point.
For me, these people must undergo specific training.
The reason is that if one does Aikido only for oneself, it won't benefit anybody.
If one becomes a teacher, one will affect the lives of others.
This is why it requires special coaching.
This program is for the people who want to share Aikido, but it is not an obligation to become a teacher.
The kenshusei program is very time-demanding but also hard phsyically so some sometimes quit because of that.
Right now I have 5 kenshusei and 3 of them are foreigners.
In Japan budo dojos have in general a somewhat old-fashioned image.
I think that Aikido Kyoto has to follow and adapt according to the time we are living in.
This is the same for other arts such as Tea ceremony and Kabuki theater as well.
There are elements that must not be changed, but other things need adapt to the changes of the times. It is important to keep this balance.
I want to do the same for Budo, remove the old-fashioned image without loosing the essence.
It has to stay a Budo, so it must retain some severity.
The main thing is that I want people to find enjoyment and pleasure while they are here.
After they leave, I want them to think about and understand why the training was nice was and pleasant.
We're travelling light
Should I look towards Guillaume?